[Music]
twenty years ago and you were lead
detective on the Big Smoke case right
[Music]
I'm a journalist why this case all point
to you a murder like that only goes
unsolved if the police don't want to
solve I've seen what a book you have any
suspects 20-plus years and not one
arrest
are you guys hearing to puff uterus were
hired by Biggie's entourage we didn't
have to park him the facts points a
silver lawyer
the wicked proof of connection between
cop and Biggie's murder who we not only
break the LAPD he would ruin it a city
boy
like
[Music]
why don't you attacked LAPD's connection
Death Row Records I cannot comment on an
open investigation as long as it's an
ongoing investigation that evidence
stays locked away in the dark we are a
match stick away from blood-stained
streets every day
[Music]
you have no idea what the LAPD is
capable of we are distancing ourselves
from the story got what I need
[Music]
Oh beast was
it was only one way this was gonna
happen
you